Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vais vous parler de spatial.
Normalement, si vous n’êtes pas
spécialiste du spatial,
quand je vous parle de spatial,
vous avez en tête Thomas Pesquet
en train de faire
une sortie extravéhiculaire.
Mais il n'y a pas que Thomas.
Je vais vous donner quelques exemples
peut-être un petit peu plus inattendus,
et avant, de rentrer dans des
considérations un peu plus globales.
Agriculture de précision :
c’est une photo d’un ensemble de champs
et d’exploitations agricoles.
Ça fait des motifs géométriques
très beaux et très précis.
Derrière, c’est quoi ?
L’agriculture de précision,
c’est votre capacité à piloter
non seulement les engins agricoles
à la dizaine de centimètres près,
en mélangeant des techniques de
positionnement par satellite d’une part,
d’imagerie de l’autre,
mais c’est aussi mélangé avec des
techniques - de l’hyper spectral -
qui vont permettre de vérifier
l’état de la végétation,
de regarder à quel moment
il va être idéal et optimal, par exemple,
d’arroser ou d’utiliser
un certain nombre d’intrants,
c’est-à-dire des engrais
ou des choses comme ça.
Et donc vous allez être capable
d'optimiser votre culture.
Et donc, de nouveau, le spatial
a joué un rôle qui est absolument clé.
Autre exemple :
gestion des catastrophes naturelles.
Ici, vous avez une photo du Vésuve.
Donc, catastrophe naturelle,
qu’est-ce qu’il faut faire ?
Vous avez une catastrophe
à un endroit donné
et on en a parlé pendant toute la journée,
ces catastrophes naturelles vont arriver,
elles arrivent déjà de manière
plus fréquente que précédemment
et c’est lié essentiellement au changement
climatique qu’on vit aujourd’hui.
Qu’est-ce qu’il faut faire ?
Il faut être capable
de dimensionner les secours.
Pour dimensionner les secours,
vous avez besoin absolument de savoir
quelle est l’étendue des « dégâts ».
Et donc pour ça, il faut que vous soyez
capable de prendre des photos,
ça veut dire d’amener des satellites
capables de prendre une photo
ou de faire un certain nombre
de mesures sur le site.
Vous allez devoir aussi,
si vous en avez besoin,
amener aussi des télécoms,
par exemple, il n’y a plus de réseaux 3G,
plus de réseaux 4G, etc.
parce qu’il y a eu des destructions,
donc derrière, il va falloir
amener un satellite
qui va être capable d’assurer
ces télécommunications, etc.
Autre exemple :
c’est un magnifique lion de mer.
Vous voyez qu’il a été équipé.
Je vais vous parler un peu d’Argos.
Peut-être que ça vous dit quelque chose.
Je vais vous donner deux exemples
avec ces balises Argos,
qui permettent d’assurer
un suivi très précis de la balise
avec justement des constellations
de satellites.
C’est un projet lancé par le CNES
et la NASA il y a très longtemps.
Ici, ce lion de mer a été équipé
non seulement d’une balise Argos,
mais en plus,
il y a aussi un petit détecteur capable
de mesurer un certain nombre de paramètres
comme la température
et la salinité de l’eau, par exemple.
C'est très utile pour deux raisons.
La première,
c’est que c’est une espèce menacée,
donc on a besoin de comprendre
quel est son comportement
on a besoin de suivre les individus,
on en a besoin pour comprendre
la manière dont ils vivent aujourd’hui.
Et puis, en même temps,
on « exploite » ces capteurs
parce que ce sont d’excellents plongeurs
et ils passent leur temps
à faire des allers-retours
entre la surface et jusqu’à
1500 mètres de profondeur environ.
Donc ils descendent la colonne d’eau
et on en profite à chaque fois
pour récupérer de l’information,
température, salinité,
et on remonte cette information.
Et ça, c’est très utile
pour les océanographes
et donc pour les climatos, derrière,
parce que ça permet de comprendre.
C'est des mesures qui permettent
d'enrichir les modèles.
Toujours avec Argos :
Argos, c’est aussi ça.
Je suis sûr que vous avez déjà entendu
que tel navigateur solitaire
au milieu d’une course
transatlantique au large
a déclenché sa balise Argos.
Argos, c’est 30 000 vies
qui ont été sauvées
au cours des 30 dernières années.
Grâce à ça, c’est aussi
une capacité à prendre plus de risques
parce que vous savez
que les secours ne sont pas loin,
et aussi des projets extraordinaires
qui permettent de se dépasser,
qui ont été menés à terme avec ça.
Et de nouveau, ce sont
ces fameuses balises
et ces constellations de satellites.
Autre exemple,
et puis après,
je vais être un peu plus général,
dans le monde de l’énergie.
On en a beaucoup parlé et là aussi,
les satellites jouent
un rôle absolument clé.
J’aurais envie de dire
dans tous les champs,
Ça commence, si on prend par exemple
une entreprise pétrolière,
quand elle fait un forage, elle va avoir
besoin de repérages extrêmement précis
et extrêmement minutieux.
Où est fait le forage, comment il est fait
comment il se déroule…
Pour ça, vous avez besoin
de positionnement, de communication.
Tous ces outils sont amenés
aussi directement par les satellites.
La même entreprise,
on va être capable de la suivre
pour vérifier par exemple
qu’il n’y a pas de pollution
par une nappe d’hydrocarbures.
Demain, plutôt aujourd’hui et demain
de manière encore plus précise,
on est capable aussi, avec des satellites,
de détecter les émissions
de CO2 et de méthane
qui sont des gaz à effet de serre
qui sont extrêmement importants.
Aujourd’hui, c’est encore assez global,
globalement on est capable,
sur une région donnée
ou sur une surface assez large,
de calculer ces émissions.
Mais demain, on aura des précisions
beaucoup plus fortes
et donc on sera capable
pour une usine donnée,
de savoir s’il y a une fuite de méthane
ou s’il y a des émissions de CO2.
Et qui dit mesures dit
aussi contre-mesures.
Si vous êtes capable de mesurer,
vous êtes capable aussi,
comme pouvoirs publics, demain,
éventuellement, d’imposer une taxe carbone
ou de créer des mécanismes nouveaux
qui utilisent cette information.
Autre exemple :
l’aménagement du territoire.
Là, c’est un très bel exemple.
Vous êtes sur un estuaire
avec un système extrêmement complexe
où il y a à la fois l’océan qui arrive
d’un côté, un fleuve de l’autre,
vous avez des interactions très complexes,
vous avez des problèmes.
Comprendre et suivre les évolutions
de cet écosystème,
c’est extrêmement difficile
et on a besoin du spatial pour ça,
pour suivre le trait de côte, pour suivre
la biodiversité, pour vérifier aussi si,
demain matin, il n’y a pas
des constructions illégales
qui ont été démarrées et donc
c’est vraiment un outil de pilotage
de  l’aménagement du territoire.
Si on réfléchit un petit peu
au-delà des exemples que j’ai donnés,
juste pour vous montrer, pour
illustrer les questions autour du spatial
il y a aussi quelque chose
qui est vraiment fondamental.
C'est vrai pour le spatial, c'est vrai
pour tous les champs de la science.
Quand vous investissez dans la science,
vous voulez faire des choses,
vous avez un projet ou de la technologie,
vous partez d’un point A,
vous voulez aller à un point B.
Et puis, comme tout bon projet
scientifique ou technologique,
il arrive souvent ou fréquemment
que ça ne marche pas,
que ça ne fonctionne pas,
on n’y arrive pas.
Et puis, il arrive aussi non moins
fréquemment qu’on ait des retombées
tout à fait inattendues du projet.
Vous avez, par exemple, tous en tête…
Je vais prendre un autre exemple.
Dans les années 60, quand on a commencé
à faire des engins spatiaux,
on avait besoin de trouver
des isolants qui permettaient -
Vous savez que l’espace est un endroit
où il fait à la fois très chaud
et très froid selon votre orientation,
ce sont des conditions de vie
particulièrement atroces.
Donc on cherchait des isolants.
Donc, on a fait ces beaux isolants.
Vous voyez souvent les satellites
entourés d’un tissu doré.
Ce n’est rien d’autre
qu’une couverture de survie.
En fait, c’est la couverture de survie
qui a été construite, imaginée,
en utilisant ce développement spatial.
Si on réfléchit un peu
et qu’on garde en fait les grands champs,
non plus des exemples
mais vraiment des grands champs
où le spatial joue un rôle déterminant.
C’est sans doute le slide
le plus important de cette présentation,
c’est le climat.
Aujourd’hui, il y a un consensus
dans la communauté scientifique
pour dire qu’effectivement,
le climat se détériore.
On assiste à une forme
de réchauffement climatique.
Que ce réchauffement climatique
est lié à l'activité humaine.
Après, il y a différents modèles,
différentes évolutions.
Et c’est très important d’avoir
le plus de données possibles
sur l’ensemble de la planète,
de plein de paramètres qui sont
extrêmement variés, de température,
d’altimétrie, de questions
autour de la salinité des océans, du pH.
Il y a énormément de paramètres
extrêmement importants et qui permettent
de nourrir les modèles qui permettent
de modéliser le climat.
Ces modèles sont des modèles
mathématiques  très complexes,
des modèles maillés qui tournent
sur des supercalculateurs
de très grande taille.
Ça demande une grosse puissance de calcul,
mais surtout la précision de ces modèles,
elle vient de la qualité des mesures
et de la qualité des inputs,
les valeurs qu’on rentre dans ces modèles.
Et pour ça, vous avez besoin -
Soit vous faites des observations
ponctuelles avec des capteurs,
soit, grâce au satellite,
vous êtes capable avec des taux
de revisite extrêmement élevés -
des satellites capables
de repasser plusieurs fois
sur le même point à des fréquences élevées
et avec des précisions très élevées -
eh bien, vous êtes capables d’enrichir
ces modèles, de les rendre bien meilleurs
et d’avoir une bien meilleure
compréhension de ces modèles climatiques.
Une bonne compréhension
de ces modèles climatiques
permet aussi de comprendre
sur quelles variables on peut jouer demain
et comment on peut agir pour essayer
de travailler sur cette question
du réchauffement climatique et d’anticiper
les changements qui vont advenir.
Donc, c’est absolument essentiel.
Pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur : aujourd’hui,
l’altimétrie, la mesure
de la hauteur des eaux,
qui est un enjeu absolument
central pour le climat,
on est très très bons en France,
on arrive à mesurer,
avec une précision de 0,5 millimètre
à peu près, la hauteur des eaux,
et pas simplement à deux ou trois points,
mais sur l’ensemble du globe.
Ça permet d’enrichir
et de mettre plein de données
dans les modèles qui permettent
de modéliser le climat.
J’ai parlé climat,
deuxième grand sujet
qui est très important,
on ne peut pas y échapper
quand on fait du spatial,
c’est la question autour de la défense
et de la dissuasion.
Tout le spatial travaille
dans une forme de dualité,
aussi bien sur la question des lanceurs
que sur la question des satellites.
Vous voyez, au centre,
il y a une superbe Ariane 5
qui est en train de décoller de Kourou.
Ariane 5, c’est notre lanceur actuel,
Ariane 6, c’est le prochain lanceur
qui va arriver dans quelques mois.
Vous voyez à gauche le M51
qui est le missile de dissuasion français.
Il n’y a rien qui ressemble plus
à un missile qu’un lanceur
et réciproquement.
Donc il y a toujours eu
une forme de dualité.
Les gens qui font des lanceurs font
aussi des missiles et réciproquement.
Et les grandes puissances spatiales
sont aussi les puissances
qui ont cette capacité
de missiles stratégiques.
Le deuxième point, qui est vraiment
fondamental : il faut donner -
Nos forces armées, nos forces de défense,
ont besoin de trois choses.
Elles nous demandent trois choses :
de voir ce qu’il se passe
sur un théâtre d’opération,
ça veut dire avoir des systèmes
d’observation optiques ou autres
mais qui ont des précisions
évidemment bien meilleures
que les images de Google Earth,
comme vous pouvez l’imaginer.
Elles veulent aussi être capables
de communiquer de manière sécurisée,
c’est-à-dire communiquer entre elles
sans que personne ne les écoute.
Elles veulent aussi essayer
d’écouter ce qu’il se passe,
pas tellement
le contenu des conversations,
mais plus savoir qui est en train
de communiquer avec qui
sur l’ensemble du globe.
C’est donc énormément de travail aussi
des satellites dédiés qui sont spécifiques
et consacrés à ça et qui sont absolument
cruciaux et très utiles
dans tous les conflits, y compris
ceux qu’on connaît aujourd’hui.
Le spatial, je l’ai appelé
le laboratoire ultime.
C’est un endroit
extraordinairement hostile.
Je vais en reparler dans 30 secondes.
Mais au-delà de cette hostilité,
c’est un endroit où on est capable
de faire des expériences
et des manipulations
qu’on ne peut faire nulle part ailleurs :
vous n’avez pas de gravité,
c’est le vide absolu,
c’est les températures très basses, etc.
Il y a plein de bonnes raisons.
Et donc il y a plein de missions spatiales
qui permettent, par exemple,
d’explorer des lois fondamentales
de la physique
et de faire des expériences
pour les vérifier, pour les affirmer,
et donc pour développer notre connaissance
sur des choses très fondamentales.
C’est aussi des missions spatiales
qui vont être capables d’aller questionner
notre univers et de « remonter
dans le temps » à travers des observations
pour comprendre ce qu’il s’est passé
après le Big Bang
et donc c’est la quête de nos origines.
C’est aussi des missions
d’exploration planétaire.
Donc, vous voyez évidemment
une superbe mission martienne
avec le petit hélicoptère Ingenuity.
Notre grande fierté,
une grande fierté française -
je suis un peu chauvin, désolé -
c’est qu’on est dans toutes
les missions martiennes de la NASA
pour une chose qu’on sait
très bien faire, c’est les caméras.
Ce ne sont pas des caméras,
c’est la KEM cam.
C’est la tête du robot
que vous voyez tout en haut,
C’est un laser qui va vaporiser
un peu de roches
et qui derrière va être analysé.
On va être capable de connaître
la composition exacte et précise
de ce qui a été vaporisé.
Donc on est sur toutes les missions
autour de ça
et on est aussi en France
l’équipe qui a fait le sismographe
qui a été envoyé sur Mars.
Juste pour dire qu’il y a plein d’autres -
là, c’était Mars -
mais il y a plein d’autres sujets
passionnants qui vont arriver
avec des missions :
la mission Joyce autour de Jupiter,
les missions Mercure qui vont commencer
à rendre leurs données,
une mission qui a été lancée en 2018
et qui va commencer
à être pleinement exploitée en 2025.
Il y a plein de missions incroyables
qui vont arriver dans pas longtemps.
Stay tuned, comme
disent nos amis américains.
Et pour terminer, évidemment,
quand on parle de spatial, il faut
parler un peu de science-fiction.
Est-ce que c’est
de la science-fiction ou pas ?
Je vous laisserai en discuter.
Donc on est sur Mars -
Je ne sais pas si c’est Thomas Pesquet,
Probablement pas Thomas Pesquet
parce qu’il sera déjà un peu trop âgé.